safe moon responded and they want to sue
well at least their holders do i'm going
to sue coffeezilla for defaming safe
moon without any factual evidence and
hurting the thousands of investors time
to sue coffeezilla for defamation of
safe moon wow clearly i struck a nerf i
really angered people like mr b here who
describes himself as easy going and
open-minded now this open-minded man
after my video said he wanted to sue me
20 different times and that's what i
knew i screwed up i kicked the beehive
not only that the ceo john carrone
finally came out to defend his company
from all these serious allegations and
posted this in response
[Music]
oh wait sorry that's not it um the
actual response was this i continue to
make the conscious choice to not take
the bait of halting work to address the
reams of false information being posted
so
he basically dodged the allegations like
he's neo in the matrix and now just so
we're clear he he did post that meme of
the guy pounding his chest from wolf of
wall street it just wasn't in response
to me although it could have been
because that whole scene is basically
about stealing money from investors
which is what i accused him of name of
the game move the money from your
client's pocket into your pocket
but despite john's dodge i still wanted
to understand the safe moon army the
good people who were down 90
on a bad investment how could they still
be so positive about safe moon so i
hosted a couple of spaces for them to
explain their position to me i wanted to
know how you can still hold a coin that
appears to be so obviously a fraud um
and i think that was kind of my mindset
in many other people's mindsets there
was bad actors on board and it seems
like now there's kind of been an entire
shift and they are trying to move
forward with what is looking like a
legitimate project what's truly the
fraud here is it john caroni himself
could you separate john caroni from
safewood would it still truly be a fraud
could it not be a fraud no no i
completely agree like i'm 100 there with
you on ben phillips and anybody that's
proven i was but that's no i 100 agree
on that yeah i 100 agree i was
specifically i'm sorry i should have
clarified talking on the last point
about john's wallet because that's where
the that's what everybody's last pillar
of hope is in right now and there it is
it seems like the common belief is that
the old team was bad yes safe moon used
to be a fraud but karoni
saved it and all the evidence that i
found about caroni taking money was just
fud and at this point i realized maybe
no amount of evidence would ever satisfy
these people i mean
what would i really do
double down and look for even more
evidence of john committing fraud
let's start with what we know john
caroni lived in a van or trailer before
safe moon in other words he was not rich
suddenly safe mode happens and corona is
in charge of a multi-billion dollar
market cap and there's a pool of money
that is supposed to be locked up but
isn't now in the last video i showed you
how safe moon lp was being siphoned from
bitmark for millions of dollars in
profit for safe mode and some of those
millions appeared to have ended up in a
wallet caronie controlled called the
gabe wallet this was the first known
wallet of caronies and according to papa
aka thomas smith that's a tana wallet
tano is a company that john controlled
and it has nearly four million dollars
in it most of it from bitmart which as
we know safe moon was making millions
from misappropriating funds that should
have been for the liquidity pool as
promised so any proceeds of that should
have gone back in the liquidity pool but
never was okay i know we're catching up
on a lot but the question is how are
these funds being used if it's not for
the lp there's two narratives you can
believe either a this tano thing was
mostly a cover story because jon owns
tanos so it's just really his personal
wallet or
b tano has a fiduciary duty to safe moon
and this wallet is being responsibly
used it's just a development fund so how
do we find out which is which our first
clue comes on april 23rd 2022 i got an
anonymous tip saying that caroni had
used his so-called company wallet the
gabe wallet to buy a shin called stonks
on the recommendation of none other than
ben phillips quote been tipped while the
team was in the gambia john bought
enough to make him a top whale and for
those of you who don't remember by the
way ben phillips is a known pump and
dump artist who made 12 million dollars
from safeman okay he then linked a photo
of ben phillips in a group chat saying
this guys one of my super powerful
social media buddies is dropping a coin
or has dropped sorry called stonks they
are in with jeff bezos etc
then he says easy money for the gang
looking after the boys
and links the twitter account now if we
cross-reference this with caronie's gabe
wallet it shows that he took bin's
advice and bought in multiple times that
same day for up to a hundred fifty
thousand dollars worth of stonks tokens
that immediately made him the fourth
largest holder of stonks token trailed
only by ben phillips now this blockchain
evidence confirms our anonymous tip and
it suggests that the gabe wallet is not
merely a company wallet because what
company recklessly gambles 150k
on a meme coin on the recommendation of
a pump and dumper like ben phillips now
just for the record after bin phillips
and caroni bought in ben would notify
his followers of this tip two days late
he says okay i'm taking an absolute
gamble on this new coin called stonks
token let's go it's got meme coin energy
with a plan this disaster not only
showed that karoni was listening to ben
phillips for tips but also that he seems
to be willing to spend money from this
so-called company wallet on random meme
coins he also bought a bunch of other
coins like beefy dot finance he spent a
hundred fifty thousand dollars on and he
also bought twelve thousand worth of
phantom and this leads us to the
conclusion that a the four million
dollars in that wallet is john's
personal money or b he's co-mingling
personal and company funds which would
be even more alarming but we actually
have more than this our second piece of
evidence that caronia's misappropriating
funds comes from nfts because i've long
suspected several wallets being caronies
besides the gabe wallet but i struggled
to prove it a hundred percent so i just
never mention them until one day i'm
scrolling through twitter and i see this
post this guy says fonz any thoughts on
what who the devil wallet by that
they're pointing to a wallet that starts
ox-666 there's four million dollars usdc
sitting in it and a couple of nfts the
reply comes from fonzie aka real fudd
who says no idea the only thing i
noticed was the moon dog nfts in the
wallet which jack haynes and ben
phillips were shilling a while back now
honestly this took me off guard because
this is a wallet i long suspected of
being coronies but i didn't know that
ben phillips had shield moon dogs before
i didn't even know caroni had any moon
dogs but from this last case we know
caroni would listen to ben phillips so
it made me look back through ben
phillips archives is it true he was
shilling moon dogs well it turns out yes
on august 14 2021 ben phillips says this
it's safe to say i'm obsessed with moon
dogs nft view my collection here now
moon dogs is not affiliated with safemen
which makes this response under it
strange john caroni 20 minutes later
responding with his own nft saying i
named him captain hoddle now this is
perfect because we can trace this nft
back to the buyer and sure enough on
august 14th we find that this moon dog
number 162 was bought by none other than
the so-called devil wallet ox-666
and this means this is cronie's wallet
because it was purchased the same day he
tweets publicly about owning it and this
is where it gets really interesting
because this wallet after buying twenty
thousand dollars worth of nfts you know
what it has in it another four million
dollars usdc and where did it get all
that money well it started as 12 million
dollars of tether coming in from places
such as bitmart which gave them eight
million dollars and then another four
million came in from ox d51 also known
as the infamous gabe wallet this wallet
then exchanges that usdt for usdc but
this is a double confirmation that this
is caroni and the implications here are
massive because not only is carony
making millions and putting it into
so-called company wallets which are
buying a hundred fifty thousand dollars
worth of meme coins he's also pumping
millions from that account and from
bitmart into what only can be described
as personal wallets because once again
what company wallet would buy twenty
thousand dollars worth of nfts such as
moon dogs but here's the deal it doesn't
even stop there because two of caronie's
quote moon dogs were transferred on
february 15th to another one of carone's
wallets giving us more evidence and how
do we know that it's caronie's wallet
and not a new buyer of this coveted moon
dog well because it was a transfer not a
cell and to add to the evidence look who
it's getting funded from this wallet
ox35a is getting half a million dollars
from the gabe wallet and it gets 100k
from the so-called devil wallet as we
speak this wallet which i'm going to
call the moon dog wallet has an
estimated value of 1 million dollars on
ether scan and another half a million on
bsc scan we can actually calculate how
much coroni controls here with a service
called eight board dot finance which
calculates wallet holdings across
multiple chains and with the three
wallets we know of we so far have a net
worth across caronie's wallets of
roughly nine million dollars but that's
not even all because as i said earlier
this so-called devil wallet got 12
million usdt there's only four million
left what happened to the rest well a
lot of it was eventually sent to a
kraken deposit wallet which looks to be
also controlled by
you guessed it caroni because 18 million
dollars came from wallets such as
bitmart our devil wallet and the gabe
wallet and one other wallet which we
don't even recognize and the point here
is not that we have all the answers by
any means questions certainly remain
like for example what is that 18 million
dollars being used for if caronie's
using these wallets personally what are
the implications is it reasonable for a
ceo to go from a trailer to being paid
nine million dollars in one year while
investors are down 90
especially when that money appears to be
coming from the lp so i want to be clear
i'm the first to admit we need more
answers like why caroni is cashing out a
million dollars at this coinbase wallet
or why he's cashing out another million
dollars at this coinbase wallet or yet
another kraken wallet another million
dollars but even with the questions
remaining don't forget about the facts
we do have like these three accounts
which hold over nine million dollars all
of them linked to caroni and many of the
transactions appearing to be very
personal in nature buying meme coins
buying nfts bragging about those nfts
listening to what ben phillips says of
all people
it all paints a very dark picture that
caroni is not the savior of safe moon
like many believed but rather
perhaps is just another hustler that's
basically it for this investigation pump
the stock and thanks for watching